اعلنت الجزائر تقديمها مبادره لحل الازمه
في النيجر تقوم على فتره انتقاليه مدتها
سته اشهر تقودها شخصيه مدنيه متوافق عليها
وكان قاده الانقلاب في النيجر ابقوا على
حاله التاهب في صفوف قوه المسلحه بينما
حضرت باريس غدا انتهاء مهله طرد سفيرها في
النيامي مما سمته طريق الكارثه المؤكده في
النيجر وخطر انهيار الامني في غرب افريقيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما ابرز عناصر
المبادره الجزائريه لحل الازمه في النيجر
والى اي حد نجحت في توفير حل وسط يلبي
مطالب وانشغالاتي جميع الاطراف المعنيه
بالاسماء كذلك ما دلاله ابقاء قاده
الانقلاب حاله التاهب القصوى في صفوف
الجيش بموازاه استمرار تصعيدهم ضد باريس
وما مدى دقه التحذيرات الفرنسيه من احتمال
حدوث انهيار امني في غرب افريقيا
واخيرا ما فرص توافق اطراف الازمه
المختلفه على حل سياسي يضع حدا للتوتر في
النيجر في هذه المرحله وما الحدود الدنيا
التي يمكن ان يتوافقوا على اساسها في شان
هذا الحل
[موسيقى]
بعد جولات واتصالات تقاسم انجازها وزير
الخارجيه ووكيل وزارته في الفتره الماضيه
وشملت النيجر ودول الاقليم وجهات دوليه
ذات صله بانقلاب او بالازمه في النيجر
كشفت الجزائر عن مبادره لحل الازمه
النيجيريه قال وزير الخارجيه احمد عطاف
انها تتكون من سته محاور لم يكشف تفاصيلها
تقوم على اساس فتره انتقاليه بقياده مدنيه
لانجاز ترتيبات يشارك فيها الجميع وفق
الوزير الجزائري
صياغه ترتيبات سياسيه
بمشاركه وموافقه جميع الاطراف
في النيجر
دون اقصاء لاي جهه مهما كانت
الايه على ان لا تتجاوز مده هذه الترتيبات
السته اشهر مثل ما سبق ذكره
وتكون تحت اشراف سلطه مدنيه
تتولاها شخصيه توافقيه
تحظى بقبول كل اطياف الطبقه السياسيه في
النيجر
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من يمه
الدكتور علي يعقوب الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي
ومن باريس الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جنيف
ومن ابو جه بول
مسؤول الدراسات الاستراتيجيه السابق في
الاكواس
وسابدا معك سيد جيمي ولنتحدث عن خصوصيه
هذه المبادره التي تقدمت بها الجزائر
والتي تعد اول مبادره للحل منذ بدء الازمه
في الاجر
في الحقيقه هذه ليست المبادره الاولى من
نوعها ربما هي الاولى منذ الانقلاب ولكن
عاد عن ذلك كانت الجزائر دوله مجاوره
استراتيجيه واساسيه بالنسبه الى النيجر
ولا طالما اطلعت بدور في
المستجدات وتطورات في منطقه الساحل طبعا
الجزائر هي جزء من المغرب العربي ولكن
هي ايضا في منطقه الاكواس وبالتالي اعتقد
انها مبادره حميده تاتي في وقت ملائم الان
في محاوله للتخفيف من التوترات
واذا استمعنا الى الحكومه تقول انها تريد
حلا سلميا اعتقد يجب ان نستمع الى كافه
الاطراف في هذا النزاع
المجلس العسكري الاكواس فرنسا الولايات
المتحده وكافه اعضاء الاسره الدولي اعتقد
انهم جميعا يجب ان يستمعوا الى الجزائر
لان ما سيحصل في النيجر سيكون له تاثير في
الدول المجاوره ومنها النيجيريا طبعا اذا
اعتقد ان هذا
المقترح مرحبا به وجميع الاطراف يجب ان
تتحين هذه الفرصه من اجل سير في مساره
ولكن حتى نتفهم ربما ونفهم الفرصه بشكل
كامل دكتور حسني عبيدي الامر لا يزال
غير مكتمل العناصر الوزير الجزائري تحدث
عن سته محاور
وتحدث عن فتره انتقاليه مدتها سته اشهر
وعن ترتيبات تشمل الجميع جميع ما تصورك
انت
لنوع الترتيبات التي يمكن فعلا ان تقدم حل
حقيقي خلال سته اشهر
يعني هي مبادره قابله للتحسين قابله
للافراغ ومرنه حتى تكون في النهايه منفتحه
على جميع الاطراف من المؤكد ان هذه
المبادره مطروحه لكن يمكن في النهايه ان
تعدل لكن تبقى محافظه على المبدا الاساسي
وهو لا اعتراف
بالنظام الجديد ولا كذلك قبول ورفض قبول
بالتدخل العسكري ثم ان النقطه التي اشرت
اليها وهي هذه التقليل المده الانتقاليه
تعتبر نقطه مركزيه لان مده حياه العسكريين
في السلطه اصبحت وجيزه جدا وان كل الاطراف
هي داخل النيجر مطالبه بهذا الحوار الواسع
المكثف بالاضافه كذلك الى اشراك كل الدول
الاشاره الى دول
وبالاضافه كذلك الى الاتحاد الافريقي
وفرنسا يعني في النهايه الب الاقليم
والبعد الدولي من المؤكد انه يضم فرنسا لا
اعتقد ان قوه المبادره هي انها تقطع
الطريق
يعني لا تترك الشرعيه بين بين قوسين
للتدخل العسكري باعتبار ان هناك مبادره
بقيت قضيه وهي ما هو موقف العسكري ما هو
موقف النظام الجديد لان من الصعب ان يقوم
احمد عطاف وزير الخارجيه بطرح هذه الافكار
والمبادئ السته اذا اسلم لم يكن هناك
استماع وقبول
مجموعه الافريقيه وهنا ومن هنا الدكتور
حسني ربما جاء تركيز
الوزير الجزائري على نقطه السته اشهر يعني
هو تقريبا لم يقل شيء اخر عن المبادره
باستثناء الفتره
طبعا نعرف ان قاده الانقلاب كانوا قد
تحدثوا عن فتره انتقاليه مدتها ثلاثه
سنوات
فعلا الوزير الجزائري قال نعم ولكن وضعوا
حد اقصى لها بمعنى انه يمكن ان يقبلوا
بفتره
كما يقترح الوزير الجزائري فتره سته اشهر
هل هذا برايك واقعي
يعني هو طرح عملي لان في النهايه سته يعني
سته اشهر هي كحد ادنى اي ان
ذهاب العسكر من السلطه يمكن ان يبدا يعني
بهذا الحد لكن الوصول الى الانتقال السلمي
وانتقال السلطه الى المدنيين يمكن ان تاخذ
يعني وقتا اكثر من ذلك ثم تحدث في نفس
المبادره على قضيه الحوار الوطني الموسع
من الصعب جدا اجراء حوار وطني موسع
والاستماع لكل الاطراف للمرحله المقبله
السياسيه بعد خروج العسكر في اجل قصير ففي
النهايه انا اعتقد ان الباب اصبح في
النهايه هم مفتوح لكل الاطراف ان العسكر
يحتفظون بماء الوجه لانهم في النهايه غير
مطالبين بتسريع خروجهم من السلطه
ولكل الاطراف وانا اعتقد ان الرئيس محمد
بزوم في النهايه
سيجد ضالته في هذا الموضوع بانه لا يوجد
هناك اعتراف بالنظام جديد وانما التحذير
لمرحله مقبله تكون مفتوحه او متاحه لجميع
الاطراف اخر قد تشمل بازوم او لا يعني
القضيه ليست في التركيز على عوده بازوم
وربما هذه نقطه ايضا اساسيه سيد
فيما يتعلق بالمرحله الانتقاليه والفتره
الانتقاليه كانت اكوس لم تعترض عليها
اساسا ولكن اعتبرتها طويله على اساس انها
ربما يعني ممكن ان يكون فيها مناوره
ومراوغه من طرف قاده الانقلاب الان
المبادره الجزائريه تتحدث عن سته اشهر فقط
هل هذا امر مقبول بالنسبه للاكوس ما موقف
الاكوس
ستقول باسرع ما يمكن
تامين انتقال السلطه
وهذه جمله مليئه بالمعاني الايكواس
طرح عليها سته اشهر ولكن يبدو ان هذا لم
ينجح وانتقلت المده الى سنتين لنكن
واقعيين سته اشهر لماذا تفيد هل سوف
يتخلصون من بازون من يستلم منه هل ستقام
انتخابات لكي يستلم شخص اخر او ستعينون
شخصا اخر ومن ثم ننظر في دستور في النيجر
وما ينص عليه اذا لم يكن ينص على هذا
النوع ترتيبات على المفاودين ان يجدوا
مخرجا بالنسبه الي فتره انتقاليه تتراوح
بين 12 شهرا الى 18 شهرا اي سنه الى سنه
ونصف ستكون مقبوله ومنطقيه لانه من الصعب
ان نعيد باسوم الى منصبه
والا سيطرح سؤال لماذا حصل الانقلاب
والعسكريون يدركون ذلك ولهذا
يلعبون ورقه بازوم لانه يدركون
انا هذا اداه بيدهم حتى
يكسبوا الشرعيه والمصداقيه ويحقق التقدم
طيب ربما ربما من هنا اذا سمحت سيد
الدكتور حسني عبيدي من هنا ربما جاء كما
ذكرنا ان المبادره الجزائريه لم تركز على
هذه النقطه هي قامت في الاساس على مبدئين
اساسيين وهما استعاده النظام الدستوري وفي
نفس الوقت معارضه اي تدخل عسكري المبادره
بشكلها الحالي وما نعرفها عن نعرفه عنها
حتى الان هل فعلا يمكن القول انها حققت
نجحت في تحقيق هذين المبدئين
نجحت قبل كل شيء في اعاده ديناميه
دبلوماسيه ديناميه تفاوضيه كان الحديث فقط
على التدخل العسكري كان هناك فراغ كبير في
اي بديل دبلوماسي وهذا مهم جدا في هذا
الجو المشحون النقطه مهمه وهي قضيه
الولايات المتحده وزير عطاف تحدث عن
الولايات المتحده وهذا اعتقد عمدا لانه
يريد ان يقول بانه نحتاج كذلك الى دعم
امريكي سيدتي في المفاوضات المواعيد ليست
مقدسه وانا اعتقد ان عدم ذكر الاسماء هو
كذلك متعمد لانه ستصبح القضيه هي قضيه
اشخاص يمكن ان تكون عمليه انتقاليه وفي
المبادره اذا رايت كانت هناك مصطلح
الضمانات ذكرت الضمانات ان تكونوا ضمانات
ان العسكر الذين قاموا بالانقلاب لم يكن
ليكن لديهم ثمن الحق في الترشح مثلا مثل
لن يكون هناك الحق لمحمد بازون للعوده
مرمره اخرى لكن من الصعب ذكر كل هذه
الامور المهمه والشيطان يسكن في في تفاصيل
في بدايه طرح مبادره صحيح صحيح والكل طبعا
حريص كما ذكرت لان الان يسعدني ان ارحب
بعلي يعقوب الذي ينضم الينا كانت لدينا
مشكله قصيره اكيد حزرتم استاذ علي اذا
مبادره مطروحه على الطاوله الان
واجواء مشحونه والكل يبحث عن حل والاكوس
تقول ان
يعني ما زال الخيار العسكري موجود ولكنه
في اخر المطاف هذا الحديث يتزامن مع ابقاء
قاده الانقلاب حاله التاهب القصوى
هل في هذا رساله معينه ما نوع هذه الرساله
التي يرسلها قاده الانقلاب في هذا الوقت
اولا هذه مجرد مبادره ومتى جاءت اليوم حتى
ما في ردود الافعال عليها لا من الاسكر لا
من الاكواس ولا من اي طرف من الاطراف اذا
مجرد مبادره لم تقبل اظن لا يجعل الناس
يغامرون بحياتهم
ويخلوا تاهب القصوى
الذين قالوا عن تاريخ
الهجوم اذا لا يفرطون في هذا لاجل مبادره
لم يوافق عليها احد ولا حتى لم يرد عليها
احد بالايجاب ولا ولا بالسلوى فهذا من باب
الاحتياطات يعني فهذا المبادره هذه
لا يمكن ان يحكم عليها من الان في شيء
يعني فلذلك كل شيء على ما كان حتى ياتي
شيء اخر لتغييره اي نعم طبعا للاسف لم تكن
معنا في البدايه ولكن اريد ان اسالك بخصوص
هذه الفتره فتره الثلاثه سنوات التي كان
يصير عليها قاده الانقلاب للفت ره
الانتقاليه ولكن الجزائر يقول سته اشهر هل
فعلا يمكن
ان يقبل القاده العسكريون قاده الانقلاب
بهذه الفتره وربما يلتقون الطرف الجزائري
في منتصف الطريق لقطع الطريق على اي تدخل
عسكري
مبادره الجزائريه هذه بسته اشهر هي مبادره
يمكن البناء عليها ولكن لا يمكن قبولها
لماذا لان السته اشهر لا تعيد الامور الى
ما كانت حتى يتفرغ الناس للانتخابات التي
تحتاج الى استعدادات مبكر شهرين ثلاثه
اربعه ولكن فقط الان عندنا ارضيه وقفوا
عليها لان الامور تحتاج الى كثير من
الاصلاحات اقل ما يمكن نقول ثمانيه عشر
شهره او سنتين هذا يمكن تكون هناك
انتخابات وشيء من هذا من هذا القبيل ولكن
سته اشهر لا اظن الانقلابين لا يقبلون ولا
شعب النيجر اللي يدافع عن البلاد ويحاسرون
السفاره
الفرنسيه الى نقطه مهمه يعني وسط كل هذا
قليل جدا نعم وسط كل هذا هناك التوتر الذي
اشرت اليه نعم وشك كل هذا التوتر الذي
اشرت اليه للتو عليه وهو ان المجلس
العسكري في النيجر والذي يؤكد تمسكه بطرد
السفير الفرنسي بعد انتهاء المهله التي
منحها
للسفير للمغادره طبعا ابقى حاله التاهب في
صفوف القوات المسلحه كما ذكرنا تزامنا مع
انتقادات لاذعه وجهتها له وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه التي حذرت من ان الطريق الذي
فتحه الانقلاب في النيجر هو طريق الكارثه
المؤكده وخطر الانهيار الامني ليس فقط في
النيجر انما في غرب افريقيا ككل
نطالب بالعوده الى النظام الدستوري في
النيجر نحن ملتزمون بيفاء مبدا
الديمقراطيه ولا يوجد انقلابيون يتحلون
بالديمقراطيه لا يمكن ان نتجاهل ما تقوله
اكواس بشان الوضع في النيجر ولا يمكننا
الاستمرار على نهج مالي وبوركينا فاسو
الاحداث الاخيره تؤكد لنا ان المؤسسات
الديمقراطيه مهمه والانقلابيون سيفشلون
وهم فشلوا بالفعل
اذا هذا التوتر بين باريس وانيامي كيف
تراقبه الاكواس خصوصا ان هناك حلقه
استفزاز كبيره فيما يتعلق بالسفير الفرنسي
وبقائه
اعتقد ان هذا من اكثر القضايا الشائكه
لاننا نتفهم الموقف الفرنسي لانه اذا سمحت
فرنسا لسفيرها بالمغادره هذا يعني انها
سيكون من الصعب اعاده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه نرى المتظاهرين وتصرفاتهم
يطلبون من فرنسا المغادره يحرقون العلم
الفرنسي ويرفعون علما اخرى الى ما هنالك
اذا استمعنا الى الرئيس الفرنسي ماكحو حين
كان يتوجه الى
السفراء الفرنسيين قال انه يعترف بان
فرنسا ربما ارتكبت اخطاء وهي بحاجه لتغيير
سياساتها من اجل التفاعل مع شركائه يتحدث
عن شراكه هذا الاعتراف يعني انه هناك خطا
ما في السياسه التي اعتمدتها فرنسا اتجاه
افريقيا ليس فقط في النيجر ايضا في مالي
وفي بوركينا فاسو ودول اخرى
هذا هو الشعور الفرنسي وهو يتنامى بالاحرى
هناك كرهن الفرنسيين وهو اعتراف بالخطا
انت تعتبر اعتراف بالخطا سيد باجيمي دكتور
حسني عبيدي سمعنا وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للتو تحذر من كارثه تطال غرب افريقيا ككل
ما مدى دقه هذا التحذير هل هو مبالغ فيه
كما كان الرئيس مكرون نفسه اشار في الخطاب
الذي تحدث فيه الى السفراء عن ان هناك سمع
نواشم تعتبر ان موقف فرنسا مبالغ فيه
الفرنسي في وضع صعب على مستوى الداخلي
هناك العديد من الاصوات المهمه في الاحزاب
السياسيه في الراي العام تقول بان فرنسا
في النهايه بدات تفقد تقريبا كل مناطق
نفوذها وبالتالي من الصعب على باريس ان لا
تصعد في لهجتها مع ميامي هناك كذلك نوع من
نوع من الخيبه الامل الفرنسيه باعتبار ان
الموقف الامريكي موقف بقي في الوسط مواقف
اوروبيه كذلك بقيت غير ثابته لا تدعم بقوه
الموقف الفرنسي وبالتالي باريس الان
تصعد في هذا اللهجه لكن تبقى دائما خطاب
يعني هناك صحيح توتر لكن خطاب وانا اعتقد
هو مجحف نوعا ما في حق النيجر وحتى في
منطقه الساحل يعني لا يمكن اعتبار فرنسا
بانها قاطره الديمقراطيه في منطقه
الافريقيه بالعكس يعني فرنسا تتعايش مع
انظمه استبداديه كبرى
وتعاملها معامله معامله جيده ولا يمكن
القول كذلك بان في وقت ان كانت ديمقراطيه
يعني كبيره وكانت النيجر واحه للديمقراطيه
وبغض النظر عن هذا الموقف الفرنسي علي
يعقوب هناك ازمه تعيشها النيجر والسؤال ما
مدى مسؤوليه قاده الانقلاب في تجنيب
البلاد الكارثه والوضع الانساني الذي يحذر
منه البعض ايضا ما هو الحد الادنى الذي
يمكن ان يقبل به قاده الانقلاب كحل سياسي
للازمه
اولا يا استاذ يجب ان نعلم ما في كارثه في
النيجر ولم تحدث كارثه في النيجر والله
تعالي الى كل شيء عادي فقط هي دعايه الى
ميه وتخريف الناس ما في شيء في النيجر ولا
نخاف من شيء ولم يحدث شيء في النيجر ان
شاء الله هذه فرنسا ترى ان الامر ينفرط من
يدها تخوف كل الدول الغربيه افريقيا حتى
لا يؤيد النجره والله ما في شيء في النجره
انا اكلمك في وسط العاصمه والله ما في شيء
ولا نشعر بشيء ولا نخاف من شيء وحتى لو
كان في تداخل عسكري لا تخاف من هذا ايزيد
دعايات لابد ان نبتعد عنها ولا نكون مع
النباهي فرنسا التي تريد ترى انها جرحت
تريد ان تلتهم
واقعيين
اذا سمحت سيد علي يعقوب ابقى معك يعني
عندما تقول انا لا نبالي بتدخل عسكري هل
فعلا هذا في صالح النيجر في هذا الوقت
يعني هذا الكلام والذي ردده قاده الانقلاب
هل هو في صالح
النيجر وصالح المنطقه ككل
اصلا الحرب ليس في ساليه احد الهازم
والمنتشر كلهم ليس في سالم الحرب بلاء اذا
كان مما لابد مما لابد منه ولذلك ربما
يعني ربما المرونه هذا هو كان قاسم
هل الاكواس مستعد في هذه المرحله ليظهر
قدر اكبر من المرونه في التعامل مع هذه
الازمه لاخراج البلاد منها
بالتحديد ولهذا السبب فان
من خيار التدخل العسكري ولكن العلماء
المسلمين
ورئيس
نيجيري الذي هو يراس الاكواز قدعهم
للاستمرار
بالمفاوضات والدبلوماسيه وهذا امر مهم جدا
لانه قد يساعد فان القائد
العسكري النيجيري السابق ابو بكر هو شخص
هنا كانت نيجيريا في ازمه اذا نظم
انتخابات خلال عشره اشهر انه نوع القاده
الذي يمكنهم ان يتوجهوا الى قاده الانقلاب
اعرف ان الظروف قد تختلف ولكن هذا قابل
للحياه اذا الايكواس
ترى في دبلوماسيه خياره مهما ولكنها ايضا
اشكرك من ابو جابر الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
السابق في الاكوز واشكر من الدكتور علي
يعقوب الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي ومن
باريس الدكتور حسني عابدي استاذ العلاقه
الدوليه في جامعه جناف
وطبعا نشكركم انتم متابعي حلقه برنامج من
وراء الخبر شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]